♪♪♪
>> QUAN, HOW COME I DIDN'T KNOW
NOTHING ABOUT THIS SHIPMENT
COMING IN?
>> MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT YOUR CONCERN ANYMORE.
IT'S MY OPERATION NOW.
>> YOU CUTTING ME OUT?
I THOUGHT WE WERE PARTNERS, MAN.
50/50.
>> IF WE WAS PARTNERS, THEN WHY
WERE YOU ACTING LIKE THE BOSS?
HUH?
>> YOU THINK YOU CAN RUN THIS
WHOLE THING WITHOUT ME?
>> NOTHING PERSONAL.
>> JUST BUSINESS.
>> THAT'S A GAME, BRUH.
DON'T TRIP.
I'M GONNA RUN IT JUST LIKE YOU
DID.
GOT YA COKE, YA HEROIN FROM
MEXICO.
MOVE IT TO THE STASH HOUSE.
GUESS WHAT I'M GONNA DO NEXT.
>> SUPPOSE YOU'RE GOING TO SELL
IT.
>> EXACTLY.
WHO DO YOU THINK I'M GOING TO
SELL IT TO?
>> YOU THE KING, YOU TELL ME.
>> YOU'RE DAMN RIGHT I'M THE
KING!
BUT SAY I WASN'T THE KING, AND
YOU WERE.
WHO WOULD YOU CALL TO SELL THE
DRUGS AND WHAT'S THE GUY'S NAME?
>> IF I WAS STILL THE KING, I'D
PUT A BULLET IN YOUR GODDAMN
HEAD.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
BUT THEN AFTER THAT, WHO IS THE
GUY YOU WOULD SELL THE DRUGS TO
AND WHAT'S HIS NUMBER AND WHAT'S
A GOOD TIME TO CALL HIM?
>> WHAT?
>> BITCH, I JUST ASKED YOU, WHO
WOULD YOU CALL?
HOW MUCH WOULD YOU CHARGE?
HOW WOULD YOU SELL IT?
WHAT'S HIS NUMBER?
AND WHERE DO YOU GET THOSE
LITTLE PLASTIC BAGGIES YOU PUT
THE DRUGS IN?
>> QUAN, DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
DOING?
>> YEAH, YO.
AND BESIDES, PRODUCT THIS PURE,
SELLS ITSELF.
>> NOT REALLY.
>> YO, SAYS YOU.
MAN, LOOK AT THIS HEROIN, BRUH.
>> THAT'S COCAINE.
>> IT'S THE SAME THING.
>> IT'S NOT THOUGH.
>> I KNOW THAT, FOOL.
I'M SAYING IT'S LIKE THE SAME
THING PRICEWISE.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> ENOUGH, OKAY!
LOOK, I GOT SO MUCH OF THIS JUNK
RIGHT HERE, I COULD GIVE IT AWAY
AND STILL MAKE BANK.
>> YEP, THAT'S A LOOSE PACK.
>> OOPS, GUESS I'M OUT A HUNDRED
BUCKS.
>> A HUNDRED BUCKS?
THAT'S LIKE 30 GRAND.
>> A-HA.
SWEEP THAT UP.
>> QUAN, I ADMIRE YOUR HUSTLE,
MAN.
>> THANK YOU KINDLY.
>> BUT YOU DON'T KNOW THE GAME,
BRUH.
>> OH, I DON'T KNOW THE GAME?
I DON'T KNOW THE GAME?
BITCH, I LIVE THIS GAME --
GODDAMNIT.
>> YO, YOU HIT THE WRONG BUTTON
ON THAT.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
ALL IT TAKES IS ONE BULLET.
>> THAT'S NOT HOW THAT GOES.
>> HERE, SCREW THIS IN FOR ME.
>> YO, YOU CAN'T SCREW IN A
BULLET.
>> YES, YOU CAN.
>> QUAN, YOU ARE NOT READY FOR
THIS.
>> I WAS BORN READY FOR THIS.
>> OKAY.
SO YOU GOT A LAWYER SETTING UP
SHELL COMPANIES TO HIDE THE
CASH.
>> I'M CALLING ONE RIGHT NOW.
>> NOT ON YOUR PERSONAL PHONE
THOUGH, RIGHT?
>> NAH.
>> AND YOU KNOW ABOUT SUPPLY
SIDE ECONOMICS.
>> WORD.
>> YOU CAN FLOOD THE MARKET,
AFTER ALL.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> 'CAUSE OF, UH --
THROUGH THE ACTIONS.
>> THEN YOU GOTTA WEIGH EARNINGS
AGAINST OVERHEAD.
>> OOH, IT IS HOT IN HERE.
>> OF COURSE, YOU GOTTA PROJECT
SEASONALITY IN MARKET TRENDS.
RIGHT?
SO EVEN THOUGH IT'S QUARTER FOUR
RIGHT NOW, YOU'RE SETTING UP FOR
QUARTER TWO OF NEXT YEAR.
AND YOU'VE GOT COPS ON THE PAY
ROLL.
LET THEM BUST A LITTLE BIT OF
THE STASH, A LITTLE IN THEY
POCKETS.
AND, OF COURSE, YOU GOTTA FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO GET RIGHT WITH THE
IRS.
RIGHT?
GET READY TO MAKE ALL THE
PAYOFFS TO THE LAWYERS --
QUAN?
QUAN!
>> WHAT?
>> GOT THE HANDLED, RIGHT, QUAN?
>> 'CAUSE, YOU KNOW, IF YOU NEED
THE HELP I COULD SEE ABOUT
COMING BACK ON MAYBE A PART-TIME
BASIS.
>> LISTEN TO THIS FOOL.
>> YEAH.
>> BITCH, YOU OUT.
>> OR MAYBE HE'S IN!
>> DUDE --
>> YOU KNOW, HELP WITH THE
TRANSITION AND ALL THAT.
BUT IT AIN'T GONNA BE NO
50/50 SPLIT THIS TIME.
>> OH, I KNOW.
'CAUSE I'M TAKING 80%.
>> YOU TRIPPIN', DOG.
>> OKAY.
100%.
>> DEAL.
>> WHAT?
>> BUT I'M STILL THE KING.
>> NO.
>> DEAL.
BUT I GET TO GO TO THE MEETINGS
AND ALL OF THAT.
>> NOPE.
>> DEAL.
>> BRUH.
>> SO I GUESS WE BACK IN
BUSINESS THEN.
CLEAN THIS MESS UP.
>> QUAN.
>> YO.
WHAT JUST HAPPENED?
>> THAT'S JUST THE GAME, DOG.
GODDAMNIT.
>> YOU PUSHIN' THE BUTTON.
>> I AIN'T PUSHING NO BUTTONS!